wir haben hier sogar ein iphone usb
ladekabel dabei also die sind schon hart
am original leute in meinem zimmer da
fliegt so viel technik krams rum jetzt
in letzter zeit das brauchen wir nicht
mehr das ist hier auch nicht
naja gut also war nur hey leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut ist dass jetzt gerade zu fall
genau ihre hatte man kann jetzt zeigen
mal kurz genau hier unten steht gerade
wird mir gerade mein video die apple
airports von misch für sechs euro
angezeigt das habe ich vor einem halben
jahr hochgeladen und ich habe letztens
bei instagram eine nachricht bekommen
instagram heißt die alex wie ihr könnt
mir dort auch immer wieder ideen
schreiben oder mir einfach so mal
schreiben oder wir folgen freue ich mich
drüber
auf jeden fall hatten jemand von euch
geschrieben ja alex teste doch bitte mal
diese airports die haben wir irgendwo im
test als die besten günstigsten airports
oder airport ersatz abgeschnitten
ich glaube ich habe sogar mehrere
nachrichten dazu bekommen es gibt auch
schon im deutschsprachigen raum einige
tests dazu allerdings noch nicht von mir
und da ich seit mir selber stolzer
besitzer bin und auch schon diese vision
für sechs euro getestet habe habe ich
mir gedacht kommen diese 14 euro kannst
du auch noch zusammen kratzen und habe
mir glaube ich ja genau hier für 14 euro
für macht sich diese airports bestellt
und ich bin einfach mal gespannt wie die
abschneiden wir gehen mal kurz darauf
die zwölf tws bluetooth kopfhörer
drahtlos bla bla bla und man muss ja
sagen können wir hier das case sieht
absolut aus wie im original aber das hat
man bei der wickeder ausstellen also das
ist irgendwie immer so man muss ja sagen
für dieses modell habe ich 180 euro
bezahlt ich glaube da gibt es auch schon
wieder ein aktuelles von das kostet dann
über 200 euro das ist eine ziemlich hohe
summe geld dass dieses produkt aber auch
wert ist war das jetzt richtig es
deutlich keine ahnung also ich bin auf
jeden fall stolz so airports besitzen zu
dürfen keine soundqualität
glücklicherweise noch nie verloren die
teile warum auch immer
und hier sind sie auch schon der billig
ersatz aus china kam wirklich aus china
zehn tage versandzeit kann man auch hier
immer schön an die
frauen päckchen sehen wird es auch immer
grau also das könnt ihr euch merken
alles aus china ist grau und so von der
verpackung her so und so sieht dann die
hülle aus ich war mal kurz ein paar
kleine shops hier
[Musik]
um die vielleicht mal ganz kurz mit den
originalen zu vergleichen hier haben wir
original hier haben wir die fakes 180
euro 15 euro
das kassel ist ja auch immer das ist
einfach genau die gleiche größe hinten
ist auch eigentlich komplett genau der
gleiche upload drauf auf beiden also man
muss sich das mal vorstellen wie viele
firmen es gibt die das einfach eins zu
eins zu kopieren und nachmachen können
bilder eigentlich also von der
verpackung her unterscheidet sich da
nicht viel
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wenn ich die
aufmache wir haben hier sogar ein iphone
usb ladekabel dabei also die sind schon
hart am original gebt euch das mal das
einzige was die fakes jetzt davon
unterscheidet ist ein ganz ganz kleiner
punkt hier und sonst das ist halt
wirklich genau gleich weil bei diesen
wunsch teilen zum beispiel da weiß ich
noch dass die sich von der verpackung
her also die hatten auch so einen laden
case dabei und das hat auch einigermaßen
funktioniert allerdings sah das schon
anders aus als es jetzt bei denen hier
der fall ist und dass man auch sagen
muss dass es sogar magnetisch also das
hatten die wikinger auch nicht also das
ist wirklich krass ja man merkt ein
qualitätsunterschied also das lade case
ist deutlich hochwertiger aber das ist
ja auch logisch gut jetzt geht es mal um
die kleinen er platziert alter ohne spaß
und hedi blicken gegen wie rot und blau
aber sonst sehen die auf eins zu eins
aus wie die originalen ich zeige es euch
hier super gerne nochmal im beauty shot
dass das immer rechtlich möglich ist
dann finde ich echt oder dass apple
nicht gegen folgen kanada habe ich auch
schon so oft erzählt aber gut oder gut
warte mal okay ich könnte jetzt schon
wirklich gar nicht mal sagen was ihr da
fake ist und was der original
ich glaube aber kann man die fans sind
ein ganz ganz ganz ganz kleines bisschen
länger hier habe ich jetzt im flecken
hier den originalen
ich glaube es fällt absolut überhaupt
nicht auch original fake also für die
damit ein bisschen flexen wollen
erreicht oder für 15 euro an für die die
allerdings auch eine gute soundqualität
haben wollen er nicht deswegen bin ich
mal auf die soundqualität von meinen
fans sehr gespannt schade ist natürlich
dass ihr den sound jetzt nicht
ihr könnt aber verlasst euch da gern auf
mich also wenn die sich annähernd so gut
anhören wie die originalen airports dann
sage ich das auch so und bin wirklich
begeistert
allerdings sind wir noch nicht da darauf
hat sich was heute der akku ist
irgendwie leider leer bei dem einen oder
der iss kaputt ich habe keine ahnung
deswegen muss sich jetzt erst mal noch
aufladen aber auch hier merkt man also
die qualität ist wirklich nicht gut wenn
man da die originalen airports hat dann
merkt man direkt eine riesige
unterschied aber die sind jetzt am laden
ich mache mir mal kurz im café wir sehen
uns dann gleich irgendwie weiß ich gar
nicht ob die laden oder nicht doch wird
man jetzt müsste es gehen alles blinkt
der andere auch also ok geöffnet erkennt
man auf jeden fall unterschied die
originalen machen gar nichts die anderen
blinken die ganze zeit blau und rot
wahrscheinlich weil die unbedingt jetzt
noch von mir getestet werden wollen wir
haben hier sogar eine kleine chinesische
beschreibung dabei geht es den ziemlich
vielen verschiedenen farben
allerdings kann er doch hier ist eure
englisch bluetooth an jetzt hin auf den
knopf drücken dann sollten die gleiche
erscheinen
ich hoffe das perfekte zwölf ja- und
leute ich bin so gespannt ob man mit
dieser ach du scheiße ich glaube ich
gesagt wenn die ganze zeit so eine
frauenstimme connected das hört sich
grausam an
um ehrlich zu sein jetzt hören wir mal
ein bisschen hier ich mache jetzt mal so
ein bisschen musik an und ihr werdet an
meinem gesichtsausdruck erkennen ob die
soundqualität gut ist oder
[Musik]
ok recht kurze musik empfehlung metrix
supergeiler rapper hier lag diesmal ab
kann ich euch nur empfehlen ist zur zeit
absolut mein lieblings rapper und ich
muss sagen die airports sind auch mit
meiner lieblings airports für günstig
also da kann man sich auf jeden fall
nicht beschweren am anfang dachte ich
ach du scheiße was ist das denn für eine
frauenstimme die hier in meinem kopf
weil das ging echt gar nicht klar aber
sobald man musik hört natürlich ist das
sounderlebnis jetzt nicht so krass sich
bei diesen hier trotzdem würde ich sagen
für 14 euro 85 übertrifft es absolut
meine vorstellung also ich hätte gedacht
dass wir schlechter ich habe euch einen
guten vergleich dazu sagen und zwar
hören die sich genauso an wie alle
kopfhörer die ich früher benutzt habt
bevor ich apple kopfhörer bekommen habe
mit denen ich jeden morgen zur schule
gefahren bin und das waren keine
airports oder sonst war es da war ich 14
15 16 jahre alt und da war ich immer von
zufrieden mit dem sound also ich muss
wirklich sagen wer auch immer diese
jetzt zu den besten günstigsten airports
gekrönt hat derjenige hat auf jeden fall
recht also meiner meinung nach absolut
in ordnung das heißt wenn ihr jetzt sagt
ey welche hätte ich gerne ich habe euch
mal in der video beschreibung verlinkt
wobei die bei amazon sogar 30 euro
kosten
ich habe irgendwie aus china bestellt
wie schon gesagt und ja ich bin mir
sicher da wird niemand unzufrieden sein
für diesen preis deswegen also voll
zufrieden cooles produkt kann man machen
muss man nicht aber ja es hat mich
überzeugt das was von diesem kleinen
erber test ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen das noch nach oben da schickt
mir gerne weitere produkte von welcher
website auch immer website genau über
inseln zu oder schreibt sie in die
kommentare ins all um alex wie abonniert
den kanal blogger aktivieren und wir
sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder gibt's
neues video porträt ciao